et pour nos amis qui nous regardent ce
soir est-ce que dis bonjour Est-ce que
tu est-ce que tu voudrais pas est-ce que
tu voudrais pas nous chanter ton tout
dernier tube très un truc biené ok ah
c'est bien
ça ça marchera ça bleu bleu le ciel de
Provence blanc blanc blanc le coé qui
danse dan blan blanc le soleil de plomb
est dans tes yeux mon rêve en bleu swing
ça jaune citron
non et bien quand j'ai besoin de
vacances je fais un lapin sauce motarde
c'est pas les paroles c'est pas les
paroles originales mais je l'ai fait
avec des coquillettes qui coquillent
d'ailleurs et je l' fait revenir dans
une crème fraîche avec du SAL du poivre
met de la moutarde et les coucous font
coucou bleu bleu le ciel de
Provence blanc blanc blanc le Goé bateau
blanc qui dan PL blanc le soleil de plom
et dans nos yeux nos rêv faudra prendre
des
paroles évidemment c'est touteville
c'est toutev qui
passe oui qui trouvent le moyen
d'alaudir tu fais partir là c'est qui va
faire
attention te
dis le vent va
tourner
le virage est dangereux il te faut
[Musique]
évoluerable regarde autour de toi et ne
t'entête
pas ton style est démodé alors bon ah
alors décide toi allez qu'est-ce que
j'apprends
[Musique]
qu'estceonend tu te
dis
oui ça va
bouillir le lapin va être
prêt
resteun ser
celuioute S N reste qu'un tu seras
celuiavant and RA ch à N
chanterelle ça par exemple ça c'est pas
mal c'est bien de
mage de
travailler chaque jour pour gagner sa
vie faut se
lever mais pour le
reste
heureusement merci la vie l'amour ça
fait passer
ça il pleut ma mère dans mon grenier
le vent
les mais pour le
reste mer viour fait
pass
[Musique]
temp
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]